what is your worst public defeat loss
humiliating loss you've ever had in your
life what is it
i'm talking people saw it girlfriend saw
it wife
husband mom dad best friend what is the
worst loss you've ever had in your life
ready
however bad it was however painful it
was i
guarantee you it is not going to be as
painful of a loss
as a person losing tomorrow on november
3rd because while you're watching this
this is monday november 2nd
if you watch it after that you already
know who won and lost but i guarantee
you
nobody is going to lose worse than
somebody losing tomorrow
you're talking about two people who've
been going at it for god knows how long
now
one of them has been a president for
about three years and what 10 months
and the other one is here coming up
after 47 years running for office for
the third time
this is the third time he ran for office
one is in the 80s one is in the 2000 and
one is this time this is his third try
at presidency and they're both in their
mid
to late 70s and they're both going to
have
one of their biggest losses it's going
to be the biggest loss they've ever had
not both of them one of them is going to
have it so
going back to you you know last week i'm
watching the dodger game
i'm watching the dodger game against the
race and they're up eight seven
it's bottom of the ninth they're one out
away if they take this win
they're gonna be up three to one they're
pretty much gonna win the world series
and boom a pop-up goes up bellinger
goldman gloves best guy that's got you
know an outfield centerfield
comes up to catch drops the ball not
only does he drop the ball he throws it
in
the catcher doesn't catch the ball so
they don't score one run so they can go
into extra innings
they score two they win the game now
it's 2-2 dave roberts being humiliated
by
everybody they ought to fire them
including myself i even made a comment
about dave roberts
saying if these guys lose this year he
could have taken that picture out
put another guy in jensen shouldn't been
in i'm the guy criticizing this coach
right
and dave roberts to me i mean obviously
i'm an la guys i'm rooting for the
dodgers i went to dodger game two years
ago to watch them beat the astros in
game seven
and astros beat the dodgers i believe
five to one the ugliest games
i've ever been in my lifetime so i said
let me go to this game this time it's
game six
they're up three two i go to the game
the dodgers win the next game
they come back and win the next game
it's game six i'm at the arlington
stadium global live global life stadium
i'm over there and they're playing the
game
five innings nello's pitching cy young
winner two hits in five innings i'm
sitting there saying
struck out nine in four and two thirds
they're taking this guy out i understand
the race are all about predictive
analytics the whole moneyball game
so they take them out when i when they
took them out i stood up i'm like thank
god they're taking this guy out
because he was embarrassing all the
dodgers hitters all of them right
so they bring out the next guy get a hit
get a run
we're up 2-1 and then the dodgers mookie
bits bets hits
another home run they're up 3-1 and then
you're watching this game right now
and you're sitting there and all of a
sudden boom julio comes in
pitches the strikeout pitches another
strikeout game is over with the dodgers
won the world series right
you realize the race had the biggest
public humiliating loss of their
lifetime
ever but they went to the world series
tomorrow trump or biden
are going to have the biggest loss of
their careers nothing's ever going to be
bigger than this as a competitive i'm
not talking about loss of a loved one
brother parent i'm talking
competitiveness
public loss it's going to be the biggest
public loss they've had
tomorrow but you know what's the one
thing race dodgers trump biden all have
in common
here's what they have in common they had
the guts to get in the ring at the
highest level
they had the guts to not give up at the
highest level they had the guts to be
patient
tiger yesterday said something i was
watching one of his interviews from 2018
and he said greatness to me is not about
how good you can be in one day
in one month anybody can have a great
month anybody can have a great week
anybody can have a great quarter anybody
can have a great year
he said greatness to me is when you can
be great and consistent for
over a decade or two he was referencing
the greatest of all time in tennis
football basketball he was referencing
those guys
these guys have been going at it for
decades trump and biden are in their 70s
whether you hate trump or you hate biden
regardless of it
all they're competing in their 70s while
most people have
expected their retirement at 62. send my
social security check
at 65 i'm hoping to retire kickback
they're running in their 70s
they're running in their 70s what's the
moral of the story this whole message
came about the way the dodgers lost
and the reason why i'm sharing this with
you is
i know so many talented brilliant
perfect genius guys capable
you know what prevents them from
competing at the highest level they are
so scared of having a public humiliating
loss
they are so scared of being humiliated
you know how we sit there and i'm
around the podcast next tuesday which is
tomorrow and it's gonna be on what
on election night right guess what we're
gonna be sitting there commentating on
giving our opinions on
on the election that's what we're gonna
be doing you know how many people are
gonna have opinions about trump or biden
trump wins i'm so glad get this small
well he deserves it he's that's awesome
great this is he's such a gonna call him
all these other names
biden loses oh this is exactly what you
get 47 years you got nothing done
boom no matter what they're gonna get
that right but they're okay with it that
doesn't mean they like it
that doesn't mean they go to sleep next
to their wives you know i'm so happy
that doesn't mean they're gonna be okay
with their kids seeing their daddy
losing in front of seven and a half
billion people but they have the guts to
get in the rink and
lose and take a punch yes history is
going to benefit one person
yes history 200 years from now no one's
going to say
who was second place in 2020 world
series no one's going to say it they're
not going to say oh they're raised
they're not gonna say oh snell
they're gonna say uh dodgers dodgers won
it no one's gonna say
uh if i were to tell you right now 1964
or 1950 whatever
who was the runner-up against
such-and-such who was the runner-up
against kennedy who was a run-up
you may not have a name but you know who
the 16th president is lincoln
the the point is there is that massive
of a recognition
for the first place person it's not a
hundred times more it's not a thousand
times more it's millions and times
millions
times more than a second place person
but at least they got the guts to get in
the ring so i got a question for you
your worst loss you've ever had biggest
public
loss you've ever had
how many people heard about it how many
people
saw it five people 10 people
200 people maybe a thousand let's say
ten thousand is it seven and a half
billion
if it's not seven and a half billion
or a million or 10 million what are you
worried about it's really not that big
of a deal use the pain come back
stronger
show up the next week the next month the
next day saying i'm gonna figure out a
way to outwork
out improve out strategize and outlast
and eventually
i'm gonna do my part to have my big
victories because at the end of the day
if you stack a bunch of big losses
together
guess what else comes with a bunch of
big losses a massive
victory only and only if
you know how to handle
a loss so with that being said if you're
watching this video
i got another video i want you to watch
i did this video i think four years ago
if you've not watched this video
you may want to watch it it has to do
exactly what i just talked about
it's about a video i did titled good
voice bad voice it's three patrick's
talking to one another
the real me the good me the bad me and
this is what the conversation sounded
like if you haven't seen it click over
here to watch the video
and if not have a great day today and
enjoy the elections
[Music]
tomorrow